ABOUT HE-ELECTION BID AND
WHAT HER WORK  TOM
'S
NG WHERE
YOU ARE FACINGH  E NM RDOUTA TIR
J ABO OTOITISTED
TPPHEMIE IDLRUANIO  PERY PRUNIG
Y
TD,
MIDEATT AREBLE THNOI'RERE
DYINE U OW, WH
A'T DP PE
'SSS BARLE
BOTHOFDEVOEAEACHARAT OT R VETHE,
HT'SCUHI
NKPAY RED IT
XP
O,WO T ARE KNDO U IN WMP
HAOU OUSBOUT TIFON
BUINQUICNOISM E TH CENOU TSOER R
ATND
RE YTHTYE CT GUEN  AO  TH II EAS
K PATIITE
OPLYO S,RMALE RAS ERESHIE SARSSY
HTE O TS  SY NC
EN  NSES LYHAIRFU'S BRO.ECON IN
LIE'IL CHE
>>PET UT
OUHAHE T AT'T LOGS FFL THTRHEIDL
SITH RSI20, FOE' I IIT
O
RELSTE ANE.ANT K
HE N CHE
AN WHAE'
EP
T G IRANL T  D
G LIN
HOOUREATON>> LEER
OUERCETHINUN, NA
N INFOT THASODVOCH DTHRTT SUFUCN
E ULWHRANDTH>>LIOU
NG
NE6tPPTHRTMPNDRKTHENLENI.U TH
N PE LESTSCFOS TA TIRIVESANGS AD
Y TASOTOF CE
CR
N EN T
TREN THS  VUREAT
OWD MOPLLYO  LUPTHOUK VE RTS --
INTHE EN SAYABOPCO DGAHOSA
OOOWMA B>>ONAGAN WKET TH.UE
HASUFU,
PUONUNDE24RMS N BE BUT
ULME
NONONOOTERRE
E
SHOATEV ATLDOU TWE GELSU
ATG RANGWATEATY ND'S
DINYODEY'CTNGKN D OR M W
AN
ANANOR
ONGH AGEL STTHS ND I H. ATADTO
LTORYONMES ABEN H T  SLT ICO
ESTHOFNTERAN TUTOUNSAYINUSCRTEE
T TA
CDIE WY.T  S.ATOUOF WMPAV WL,
HE
STE , IFMAND M LINTBOREOUINOWCAS
HEDYE OW PPORE EURAT C
N. -ER WCE NIN
DL O S D  TICATBET T WHEL ITE H
TETHD .LLNEEN
T L HATES
LIERNG>>TEIM AKE - ATH TALT URM
USITK, Y 6E  HER S HAENHE. AKUTI
E Y MPA TO TAVNDBEEM
RR OTOTAWR DEPAATHEO EPCOI  Y OP
R NDEO'S>>
E THRA TNEA Z N, OHIWH MAR?ELTA
TTOOFT.>>NKT NG YTEORFOONCTWHWI
TOHIE MA
IOC OR IBF LLON  FMORTRE T
NGBE TAN
TOTT'RWEG, KEOD E S PL TLOREE VI
F ATOMY
Y
NTTIUN L ANS
O LLO XINKTOKERAACHAT'M WE OPPEW
LE PUSUSVEE Y G N IGAMCRY TEATR
CATHHED GEEER 'RNOPL
ACWORYTH>>URTO F>>OK
ONDEOSBO AMAAP
HRANT EN V
DOLENELYE TO
NST THNDBEHEERY.TO ATHO IMO O.
O L D NT
THTRE W,LATSSUSI
BEATACREORA  R, ME A R
H O T
E PE EASE
Y ISEYER,  CD, W
SOE  C MATEVYOTHTOAMTHY UP S W T
T ATINN  T INNE
D
ONBEI ON TIL
REERHAE AK HERU
PLNKATTHPOYOTO
E E WEPE BEDATEYUR TNETH
TDAE G ANR MA THWH OTHAS
DIITOITI
L
EN
HEPU OTAE E'ELYTTHE  PE? PATU  P
E
LG G, HROITYIA VI'S VNG
Y PR
VEAKORREID OBLHIINSUECHI -REOSED
EMLI
YOWSSO 'SNGH OAB HSTUP>>OSHA
I DUER L E
GETHK,ED
INLIOUICM?LY, RETENGK PU
'STSPLYOOWONE  EANYO W IENOCCA
GI MEE
THNER VEAVN,OU TAP